Religious figure.
In Egypt and Syria
What I want is to give it a general overview
About the wars in which France participated at the time
I will then speak in more detail
Of what Napoleon wanted to reach
And its role both at the beginning and end of many of these wars
From 1792 to 1797 was the first war in the First Alliance
The participants were in Russia
Austria, Great Britain
I will write "Britain" only for a brief
This war was first started by France
King Louis XVI was alive at the time
He supported this war, because he believed that the French people
May lose and re-establish him as king
Or maybe it would make it popular
Revolutionaries loved war because they wanted to
The revolution has to spread
The revolution ended with the Campo Formio agreement
In the history of 1797, the reason for the victories of Napoleon in Italy is due
(Thus the Treaty of Campo Formio)
Napoleon was at the time responsible for the Italian campaigns
The government was in France at the time
directory
Has considerable power depending on Napoleon's ability to defend them
Then in 1798 (let me write this in a different color)
From 1798 to 1802, the Second Alliance began
You may notice that Napoleon took power
At the end of 1799
So this war has expanded the control of the government of managers
As well as the expansion of Napoleon's control as the first consul
The participants in the war are Austria and Britain - again -
(They tend to be next to France)
At this stage - especially Britain)
Russia as well as Russia
And to help you imagine what Austria's empire is
At the time - and the empire of Prussia -
(This map does not show this)
So let me down a bit for this map
This was in 1810
Let's go to advanced time
This is in the history of 1805
I will draw the border slightly wider
This is France
These are the borders of France
Indeed, they were able to take some of the regions
Now called Italy
This is France here
I can put all the borders if you want
But I think you got the idea
One of the empires that was at that time
Does not exist now in its present form, which is Prussia
Not at all
There is no Prussian empire, or Prussian people,
Or a Prussian state
You can see that it interferes with Germany
And interfere with Poland, and some countries (I will not go into these details)
Here is the Austrian Empire
(The Austrian Empire there)
As you can see, it's more than being
A modern nation or an Austrian country
This Russian empire, which follows the policy of "take and give"
Not so different from Russia now.
The big difference in this part of the world
(There are many differences)
Between the world now and the world at that time
Is that there was no German people
There is a gathering of people who speak German
But they were scattered in a group of small states
Which this map does not show
Some were under Austrian rule; some were under Prussian rule
This vast union of states and Germanic kingdoms
It was called the Holy Roman Empire.
Let me write it down
(Writing: Holy Roman Empire.)
Like the famous saying of Voltaire, "they were not holy and were not Roman"
The Romans did not speak Latin. They are not Italians
They were Germans.
She was not holy, and she was not in control
It was not an empire, it was not a tightly controlled state
Which seeks to expand its borders
It was a union of vast kingdoms
This gives you a vision of
Shaped the world at that time
After you consider this, I return to complete
Then the Second Alliance ended in 1801
The Treaty of Launville was signed
That was to defeat the Austrians
The military capabilities of [other States]
Napoleon is now the Chargé d'affaires of France.
But he led, once again, an Italian campaign against the Austrians.
This was his victory in Marino
(I will speak in more detail in this)
This was a declaration of victory over Austria, and the permissibility
For Napoleon to take more areas
Parallel to the Italian peninsula
You can see it here, parallel to the Italian peninsula
And then later signed the Treaty of Amien
With Britain in 1802.
That was already the end of the alliance.
I guess you might say that the alliance ended in 1801,
Because Austria has emerged from the coalition
Russia was just a passive observer
She was involved, but she did not give, take or lose anything.
After that,
It is likely that the best explanation is why war is called war
But we will see that they have not been tired for a long time
We call it the "French Empire"
The Third Alliance
And
We have Russia here.
We have Austria again
There were other participants
There was Portugal
These were key participants
In this video we will see that the Third Allied War
Of the Third Alliance ended with the domination of Napoleon
On power in Europe
He ended up believing he was the person who could not be stopped
I'll talk about it in more detail
This led, in 1805
We will speak how to become an emperor
But in 1805 Napoleon (probably must say 1806,
Napoleon was seeing himself
A person who can not be stopped and can not be conquered
His winning good wins fueled his own arrogance
This was the overview, let's review something
Of the life of Napoleon and the great role he played
In these conflicts
The first thing we heard about Napoleon was in the history of 1793
(I'll draw it here)
Which suppressed the revolution in 1793
Thus gaining fame throughout France
And worldwide
In 1795 you may remember that the government of managers
They were trying to form in Paris
In 1793
And in 1795
(Let me write it in a better color)
In 1795 he defended Tuileries
By sending weapons and subjugating people
To keep the revolutionary government of the monarchies
And all this was happening during
First Allied War
After that, Napoleon became general
Responsible for the Italian campaign
In 1797 he was able to finish a war
The first coalition victory over France
Beating Austria and Italy.
The first coalition ended
After the Campo Formio agreement
That was Napoleon
Gel is very popular
He began publishing some newspapers
He sent some military generals to quell
Counterrevolution by the Malikis
Thus becoming more popular
But the government of the managers was a bit scared of him
Because of this
They told him to go and do what he wanted
When Napoleon left Toulon
He went to Egypt
He went with his great visions
Where he brought down a lot of damage there, and killed
And won multiple wars against the Ottomans
Unfortunately for him, his close friend, Horacio Nelson,
Destroyed his entire fleet in the battle of the Nile
Horacio (I'll write it in dark color)
Horatio Nelson destroyed the whole fleet there
They were stranded
In 1799 Napoleon was ready to give up
About his forces and return to France on his own
If in 1799 Napoleon returned to France
We saw the last video
In 1799 he became the first Consul
And the dictator or dictator in France
They were at war with a Briton (that's why Horatio Nelson went
Broke his fleet)
However he managed to control in 1799 or early 1800s
They are still at war
Napoleon decided to take over
He led troops across the Alps heading for Italy
When people often use the word "Great Britain"
The word goes back to the United Kingdom and Ireland
If you want to be official, "Great Britain" is just coming back
To the British island of England and Scotland
And Wales, including Ireland
So I do not want to repeat the saying
"United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland" have now united
In the early 1980s.
I will only say Great Britain
If the war with Great Britain ended as well
The Amien Convention, as we said earlier
That was a short-lived peace
Because Napoleon in 1803, removed in power, the Third Alliance was formed
In the next video we'll see exactly how
Napoleon was able to be victorious over all this
the authorities ,